let's go ahead and check out jack I've
been playing Jackie a lot and I enjoy
the heck out of her hands I beat you
we've actually had a lot of really great
matches with Jackie Goro yeah so let's
do some let's do blue do uh best friends
forever here all BFF so they're in
Special Forces together and they
probably train together I mean the
roommates family friends
we're probably gonna talk to ya I'm good
sorry my dad's bigger than yours
my dad beat up shinik well-placed
warrant alright so first we're gonna go
through this shotgun Jackie but what's
their comments right so her comment move
is she has one of these quick - but that
doesn't like a quick blast at the end
she also has this quick hop hush right
and of course you can he exit and it
does a little extra damage she has this
little uh fist flurry that she doesn't
pee on which is awesome because you can
kind of add that almost elect not every
combo and it's a flashy new I love about
this character variation - if you're not
like super good at combos she almost has
like a built-in really cool looking
combo that you can start absolutely and
just like her father she's got this
crown pop sort of thing and you can
actually fake it to so you can make it
seem like hey I'm gonna do it Oh gotcha
no I'm gonna do an attack and set what's
thing that's really cool about Jackie is
that her combos stay the same across
variations but they get like a different
little twist see if I get anything on
this will
yeah well like she can she can add in
different attacks on to those combos and
we'll get into that so with this one she
has this exclusive shotgun right it
doesn't have to hit you I can just hit
the ground around there's actually two
uses for then yeah you're that far you
can stun me weird you're closer you know
we don't absolutely social kind of just
put some dirt here I and allows her to
run up because you're in that stun State
and what do you object you that I think
it also should be known as shoot you
should pretty fast character yes Africa
on and once you start to have master run
combos she is the perfect character
absolutely and then she has just a
straight shotgun blast right it's pretty
quick and you can add it in so they come
to the end of combos and a lot of things
like that
let's see yeah for the most part
kind of what she's got for this
variation she got that just quick thing
so maybe absolutely and also spacing you
know so that's pretty much it for the
shotgun jacket you want to do a that's
right yeah yeah so let's go ahead do I
want to do a combo okay neutral jump on
combo you're welcome you can use that
guys that one's free get fed up yeah I
don't think just design what I really
like about Jackie is that she has these
metal armors but they're not like
Jackson where they're like implanted
right they're almost like an homage to
Jax yeah they're kind of like gloves for
the most part like silos Howard Lowe's
yes so let's go ahead into the next one
I don't have an alternate costume I
really don't I
we're gonna go into high-tech this is
kind of the trickier of the upper
variations haven't seen a lot of reading
so I thought I'd throw him in there
that's kind of you I think a lot of
people asking for written as well this
blazer especially five days five days
know all the rate you want Raiden you
surprised me as will your enemies then
they'll get some of these all right so
now you'll notice her her gauntlets
under armor different they're kind of
more of a high-tech futuristic style
right so before she would do a shotgun
blast same inputs and everything she now
does this quick plasma blast now if you
hold it down you can charge it up right
and it does a big blast mmm now she also
has the ability to like power herself up
so now you see her fists are glowing
right so now her punch attacks do more
damage and you can actually go to a
second level of it and which will do
more damage and with this if you do her
little plasma blast you can build it up
and you can only build it up to this
final stage and when you have the full
two levels of active so that's a low
word you're saying there that was yeah
that was a very good description thank
you and actually if you go ahead and
throw it do one of those no not do it Oh
super good time BAM I just absorbed it
so you can kind of sit back and just
wait for people if they're like sitting
and zoning you oh I'm a horrible person
please do your lightning ball again she
has also an absorb and that is well hey
it wasn't right I'm sorry I apologize to
scream for that but there it is
now also she's got
she's got her power-ups right and like I
was saying before the moves start to get
different properties right so before she
would do a shotgun blast at the end now
that she has these plasma chocolates she
actually does a plasma blast right yeah
I love the one where she you throw the
projectile and it's almost like you just
having to catch next plate Candace just
gonna go ahead and take math correct so
if you get enough time to power up and
do the damage when the normal punches
it's really worth it and you can get to
stage two of it if you just do the e X
version right you don't actually have to
go through the whole stage one stage two
right you lot of plant like air to be
realised to set things up plan things
and be good for them yeah absolutely and
also her heard Eric ground pound also
it's a little bit stronger this dagger
yeah banger take some work around very
cool so that's pretty much it more
damage with the plasma gauntlets awesome
alright so now we're gonna go to another
last one my personal favorite one and
this one it's all about zoning it's so
much fun to play oh I've you've dealt
with this play with I've played against
this ones guitars what do you say good
times you mean you lose Beach a couple
times you have like once sure sure I'm
just a man yeah you're just a man just a
man I'm just a man good one
I really don't like you I really don't
care
as long as we're straight on that wing
alright so like her saying before when
this variation she has the same thing
but allows her to shoot rockets at the
end right
so you'll notice each variation the
projectile that from the Special Move
changes right mom which gauntlet yes
she now has an up rocket which it could
be x2 more rockets and which is fun
because you can kind of just combo into
run and then she also has a ground
rocket
oh so tricky so then if you if you exit
you can just go ahead and hold it go and
detonate it whenever you want which is
one of my favourite things right here so
the setups setups are awesome like this
and then of course she has machine guns
so she can stay far away and kind of
zone you out and then if you meet her in
it you can actually do an additional
rocket in that so you know like a lot of
projectiles I conduct those without
blocking and I'll take damage and then
if I keep pulling that game you can
throw the rockets at which will then hit
okay right so and like we're saying
before she's all about well not all
about but vary based on the
the run in combat right I wish I was
really good at them but I'm still
working on the right combos do you want
me to show them a fatality here um if
that's what the street wants we need to
do it thing to do alright let's do it
see that's a perfect way to get rid of
those love handles yeah pull them off
and then shoot you do the back good
definitely good stuff so that's pretty
much it for Jackie very very much
pressure
you